gaming chairs are a scam wait scam you
ever see pros and streamers sitting in
these $500 chairs and think to yourself
damn those look comfy well they're not
and even if they were they're pretty
much destroying their backs if you are
sitting in a really bad position for
your entire day it's not a question of
if it's a question of when you're going
to get injured or be in pain the modern
gaming chair was invented by DX racer
who literally slapped wheels on their
luxury car seats eventually there were
gaming chairs at tons of Esports events
so sure they can recline but they don't
actually support your back during long
gaming sessions which can end
poorly my
bones fortunately there are some great
non-cam options out there like Herman
Miller but those are pretty expensive
and to be perfectly honest you can't
really go wrong with just a good
oldfashioned office chair